Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
August 17th,
2015.
Why did I just say 17th?
Like,
like something major happened,
you know,
on this day and this day till I read years ago,
Christopher Columbus had jockish itch,
which was fatal back in the 70.
[inaudible] how the fuck would he still be alive,
Bill?
He probably died of scurvy in the c 1492 we came over here and hacked off the,
the fucking native Americans hands,
you know,
probably an unprotected sex.
Yeah.
Introduce some sort of,
I dunno,
I dunno what geneticists genetic genitalia.
Scabies said.
I say it,
I dunno people.
This has gotta be a record.
How quickly did this 53 seconds in and it just went right off the fucking rails.
There's podcast is
fucking over Jesus Christ anywhere else.
So August 17th,
just the way I said that 17th and I got all panicky.
Like why did I say it?
Like something important happened and then that fucking debacle happen.
Anyways,
what's going on?
How,
why?
Um,
it's the 17th day of August in the year of our Lord 2015 this is the year of the
a Cockatoo,
I believe in the Chinese calendar.
They have cockatoos over there.
I don't know.
I,
I been to Hong Kong.
I didn't see any,
I was only there for a day.
Um,
anyways,
so,
oh,
Billy fat,
tits,
the fucking pasty adventure.
I've been a,
I've been on a tear here and as I told you last week,
I fucked up my knee,
my knee.
I fucked the thing up.
A skipping rope.
True.
Ah,
right.
And I guess my fucking leg muscles got all tightened.
It started yanking my old ass knee,
you know,
in the wrong direction.
I started like,
you know,
just hobbling out to the car,
tippy toe and down the street.
Oh,
you know,
into the bathroom.
And he'd take that old man piss in the middle of the night.
Just wake up from a dream,
you know,
I mean,
what you drink?
What do you dream about?
At my age,
no,
going to a farmer's market and they still have tomatoes left.
Yeah.
That's a dream to me.
Wake up aroused when I have a trend.
It's a sad,
it's a sad fucking case.
But anyways,
so I stretched out and did all that shit but still lie.
It kind of fucked up on my diet a couple of days.
Um,
my uh,
my wife,
you know,
was asking,
hey,
why don't we hang out and go do something?
So we went to a museum and I fucking hate museums.
I absolutely fucking eighth.
I've told you about this before.
I hate museums with a fucking passion eight.
How quiet it is in there.
I hate people standing reading that little card next to that fucking painting
that I swear to God.
It's like I did something like that when I was five.
She got,
you know,
can somebody just go back to painting the cow in a field?
You know what I mean?
Just everything.
Just have to be like,
just smearing of cover colors,
all,
what the fuck these people are so dumb.
They sitting there staring at an acting like they see something.
Okay.
What are you looking at?
That's a light blue.
That's a darker blue and there's an even darker blow.
Yeah.
On that big square fucking canvas.
I get it.
He took different shades of blue.
Okay,
what does it say?
So there's nothing that says the guy knows how to color in a fucking square.
I didn't want to do that.
And this guy,
long time ago,
he explained it to me.
He goes,
well,
the differences,
cause I'd be like,
the little kid could fucking do that.
And he goes,
the differences as a little kid can't drug,
uh,
okay.
An amazing picture of like these people that make these abstract things,
can't they?
They're choosing the choosing to create that way.
It's like choosing to do what?
Fucking draw like a five year old.
So like I,
I know how to talk like an adult sort of,
if I go on stage and start telling jokes like a five year old,
all of a sudden I'm,
I'm,
I should be in a museum telling my jokes,
doc,
dark color.
You Suppose Shay,
who's there?
I'm fucking standing in the corner.
And all of a sudden I'm a,
I'm comedies.
Picasso.
I Dunno what happened.
We went there and she actually wanted to go see this short film.
Um,
that this guy made,
I know the Fucker,
I can't never remember anybody's fucking name,
but it was about La and growing up in La and,
uh,
down in Compton and everything like that.
And uh,
I love anything that is not a messy fucking painting.
And it's also like history of Los Angeles because there's so little history of
it.
They just fucking,
like I said before in the park,
they just pay right over this shit.
You know,
Robert Kennedy got assassinated down the fucking ambassador hotel.
That thing would have been a shrine in any other city.
This city fucking knocked it down,
put up a school on top of it,
you know what I mean?
Somewhere in the cafeteria,
there's like an x on the floor with a guy fucking bled out.
I mean,
it's unbelievable.
They just don't give a fuck.
Do you know they had one of the,
the,
one of the biggest acts of fucking terrorism as far as blowing up a building in
a collapsing happened here in la before nine 11.
The biggest one was when somebody blew up the fucking,
uh,
the La Times building,
the original one.
And I've been all over the Internet and I've walked all over downtown La.
I can't find a fucking plaque or,
or information anyway,
they just flied fuck it.
They just plowed it over the couple of oxen and then that's it.
Now they just,
you know,
they got the fucking,
uh,
the little white obelisk art deco,
we thing look in there acting like that's the only place they ever wore like
that.
The fucking thing get,
didn't get up in the middle of the night.
MMM.
So anyways,
that's what the fuck am I talking about?
That's the all the,
so when we went there,
this guy had all this,
uh,
this footage,
you know,
for basically like the Rodney King era right.
Up until then.
Now,
um,
I love that shit.
Seen the old cars,
you know,
back to the early nineties,
and everybody wanted a fucking Nissan Maxima.
Like that was the God damn car.
Right?
MMM.
Just little details like that.
And then seeing,
you know,
the beginnings of everybody,
fucking heaven,
an impala,
low rider.
And now that's almost like hackey at this point.
If you actually have an impala,
low rider with the fucking wire rims,
it's just like everybody's seen that,
you know,
it's like owning a Mustang or a 69 fucking Camaro.
Everybody,
you've seen a million of them.
So,
um,
anyway,
so we went down,
we watched that and then uh,
she took me to this place around the fucking corner,
which was a German place that sold all these different kinds of like brats and
sausages and a fucking sick as French fries like you're like your mom made and
were those big thick fucking wedges and she just deep fry the shit out of him.
They had that,
I got some sort of rabbit and something else fucking brought sausage,
whatever the fuck you call it,
and was absolutely delicious.
I had to fucking French fries.
It was like a junkie sitting in a crack house,
man.
It was fucking brutal.
And I looked over in the corner and there was two young guys right now,
like they're fucking mid twenties prime of their fucking life can eat McDonald's
at two in the morning and wake up with a flat stomach.
They were over there.
These two young fucking conch was sitting over in the corner and they had those
giant German Oktoberfest beer steins and I just sat there staring at those mugs
of beer.
They played look glanced over a couple of times.
I probably,
what the fuck is this guy looking at it like I wanted to fight.
It's like I'm not looking at you guys.
I'm looking,
I was like homer Simpson just sitting there doing the beer and um,
I actually asked the fucking waitress,
I was just like,
how many,
how many ounces is that?
How many beers is that?
Two to three beers.
He was like two and a half to two and a half fucking beers.
And I already fantasized about being off the wagon.
This is why I'm always going to be a drunk cause when I'm sober I don't go Ooh,
this is amazing.
Falling Asleep at 10 o'clock at night and waking up with energy.
I don't think that I just started thinking of how much I'm going to drink when I
go back to drinking.
And uh,
I can't wait for the fucking king season to start cause I'm going down to that
fucking place.
Probably Take Joey Bart,
nick,
you know,
he's a Pittsburgh guy.
God knows you know him a lot.
Head God knows they grew up on sausages and brought,
might even fucking go with the two of them.
Right?
Go down there and get one of those fucking giant bear stuff.
Fucking drink too with us.
Become old fucking Macy day bloated belly again.
Um,
so I fucked up there and then,
uh,
last night,
um,
I did a Gig,
didn't just outside of San Diego at the Harris Casino Valley Center or something
like that.
Really,
really beautiful part of California.
Like you come off of the five and there's all these little mom and pop stores.
I was making fun of it and shit,
but it,
it just had like that vibe of like small towns slash maybe a math problem,
you know,
which is like,
I guess that's what maverick is nowadays.
You know,
probably heroin now,
all that fucking problem going on.
And um,
okay.
And when we did the Gig,
but uh,
I actually flew down in a helicopter to the Gig I,
uh,
rented in our 44.
And I brought,
uh,
the opener,
Kevin Shay with me and I flew down with my instructor and uh,
and his brother and a dude.
It was,
it was the fucking shit.
I probably lost money on the GIG,
but I don't give a fuck.
It was coolest how we were actually going to land in the parking lot.
They actually have like a little,
uh,
area that they use as a Helo pad.
It's just this corner of the parking lot.
We were going to land there,
get out,
do the Gig and then the end get back in the fucking thing and take off.
But the thing was was it had all these mountains all around it and the main
street in had no lights and there was a lot of power lines in that type of shit.
So we was just like,
Yay,
why don't we landed a fucking local local airport and drive in instead?
Considering neither one of us has ever flown out of here,
you know,
and those are the fucking decisions you make if you want to fly safely.
Um,
they actually had a midair collision down there.
I just saw,
hmm.
This little ass airport,
I don't know how to fuck you don't see each other.
Okay.
You're not talking on the fucking radio.
I don't know man.
That's the kind of shit you just like,
you know,
when you start thinking,
stuff,
which is always dangerous in any fucking business we started getting,
you know,
I can fucking kind of keep this thing.
Well,
the hardest things when you're first fly is staying at a consistent altitude,
which is supposed to do it in a helicopter is basically look at your manifold
pressure gauge and how whatever inches you're polling.
Uh,
we sounds like I'm jerking off here,
but uh,
what am I thought it's measured in like inches of mercury.
So say if he,
if you're 21 and you look over,
it's your,
uh,
uvs vertical speed indicator.
If it said zero,
um,
okay.
You just,
then you just dial it in and you just keep it.
Okay,
21 inches is what I need to pull in.
I'll stay and keep the fucking,
uh,
God damn cyclic at where I'm at.
But I always ended up fucking it up.
And if I don't look at it for a couple of minutes,
I used to go up like 300 or down or descend 300 feet.
Now I'm kinda within like a hundred feet.
So I kind of felt better about that.
But,
uh,
so anyways,
so I flew down there and then we drove like the,
another 25 minutes,
did the Gig,
had a great fucking time,
great crowd.
And then we drove back to the airport and fucking
flew back man.
And uh,
flew back from just outside of San Diego.
We got back in about 35 minutes flying over all of this fucking traffic and uh,
just flew basically right along the coast the whole way up.
And,
um,
it was cool to do that actually kind of,
you know,
he was teaching me,
so to some instrument stuff where I'm not instrument rated in the course.
That piqued my fucking interest and now,
so a,
why the hell not,
I might do that next.
But,
uh,
as you fly in and
night,
like it's obviously way different during the day.
And I was just like,
I was just like,
dude,
I'm glad you're here cause I would be completely lost.
I don't know where.
I mean he just pointed up and go see right,
there it goes.
That's the Long Beach Pier.
You can always tell other long beach,
uh,
wharfs peers.
Wow.
What the fuck you call them?
They're all fucking psychotically lit up till it's like the third biggest,
um,
port wharf,
peer,
whatever the fuck you call it in the world I guess.
So it's always all lit up and there's all kinds of fucking x boxes and sex
slaves and blood diamonds going in and out of every fucking day.
So it's always lit up.
And we ended up landing that,
uh,
Long Beach after was closed,
which is pretty fucking cool.
And they got this thing,
I forget how many times you click it,
but when we took off,
the airport was already closed so all the fucking lights were out and every
thing and uh,
on the cyclic he just fucking click,
you know,
we basically,
if you're going to talk to the tower,
you just click it like seven or nine times.
I forget.
And when you do that,
all the lights come on,
the whole fucking field lights up.
It's the shit.
So that's what I did last night.
Huh?
Not too shabby.
Uh,
but anyways,
and you know what,
Kevin Shay was really fucking chill.
I thought he was going to be freaking out that I was flying.
He actually said it did a good job and he's,
he actually is,
he said this thing where he doesn't freak out when I'm taking off my,
when,
when he's taken off on,
he's up there,
he says when,
when whenever the plane or whatever he's in goes to land.
That's when he freaks out,
which I thought was kind of interesting to just be afraid then.
Um,
anyways,
I'm babbling here.
Uh,
so I was talking about,
Oh yeah,
so that night I fucking,
you know,
we had to leave like around three 30 and flew down about four o'clock.
So,
uh,
that was right around dinnertime.
And then I got to a casino and I'm just like,
they were like,
we got Mexican food and I'm like,
alright,
you want to talk?
Goes.
Yes.
I bought a burrito
sounding like little John there and I fuckin,
uh,
you know,
fucking just inhaled a chicken fucking burrito.
It was,
it was actually really good.
I think I have it,
I think was because I haven't eaten like that since the 4th of July.
I haven't had any just fucking food that's gonna make you fat.
Fuck.
So it was delicious.
Uh,
but everybody else there was also saying it was good and then was in the back of
my head going,
dude,
don't take it too far now.
Don't take it too far.
So then I reached for a Taco and only had one.
And,
um,
so anyways,
I came back this morning and got on the scale after I took my dog around the
block and then went on like at an hour and a half fucking hike,
weighed myself with an empty stomach.
So I would actually make weight this week.
I know the second I had a glass of water,
I fucker went up like three pounds,
but a,
I'm going to say I'm about 171 pounds this scale red,
one 68,
one 70 and one 69.4,
depending on where I put it.
So,
uh,
I just took the middle one,
one 69.4 and that,
cause I,
I hadn't,
you know,
hadn't eaten breakfast.
I had drank any water.
I just added like fucking a couple,
two,
three pounds.
So I'll say I'm one 71.
I might be a little lot,
that might be a little over,
but there you go.
Go Fuck Yourself,
man.
I've lost almost 70 pounds of fucking booze,
Burgers,
ice cream,
potato chips and all of that fucking shit.
Uh,
I feel great.
I can't wait to lose the rest of this.
Whatever the fucking it's going to be.
Whenever I lose the last,
I still can grab a nice fucking handful here,
man.
Whenever I lose the rest of this.
And then the second I get a nice flat stomach,
I'm going to get myself a gallon ice cream and one of those beer steins and I'm
going to go right back up again.
What is the point of losing all the weight if you're not going to go back and
indulge and become complete fat?
Fuck again,
right?
I Dunno.
Maybe you do.
Maybe you're doing it to have a lifestyle change.
I'm just trying to just,
you know,
I don't want to be 40 pounds overweight,
so just fucking dropped out the 20 and I'll go back to zero and then I'll be 20
pounds overweight again,
just in time for my special next year.
Big fucking booze head coming at you and I would never do that to you.
Um,
all right,
let's get to a,
is there any fucking advertising for this week?
Jesus Christ.
I've shit on so many of them.
I don't,
I don't know what is,
what is left?
Do I have anything?
Oh,
there we go.
three,
three little ones.
Remember back in the day,
used to have six.
What happened?
Ah,
stick with me through thick and through thin.
They don't give a fuck what I say.
I love this company.
He's keeps,
these people are fucking cool.
Here we go.
But up,
bup,
bup.
Mandy's me on bs.
No more sweaty balls.
Put a little mustard on this week.
Me Undies,
me on d all broads.
Where the shawls pull out your dry nuts.
Jake.
I'm in a face.
Why do a black?
I don't care about her race.
She'll like you and your fucking Dick heads.
It's all nice and tightened the Andes.
Oh yeah,
no more sweaty nights.
They got him for the ladies.
Um,
all right.
We all know how sexy confidence can be and that confidence comes from
being comfortable.
But how great you,
you can feel.
What the,
how great can you feel if your underwear is wrinkling and riding up?
I don't give a shit if it's wrinkled.
I wanted to write up the undies.
You start doing that fucking little,
uh,
Elvis.
Shaky leg,
trying to get it to come back down again.
Who?
Yeah,
just dragging along my balls.
Um,
and that's why they've created the world's most comfortable underwear for a
daily dose of confidence.
When you look good,
you feel great.
It's a cliche because it's true.
Well,
you switched it up.
If you look good,
you feel good,
you look good,
you don't feel great,
feel great,
you feel great,
you look good.
Yeah.
You feel good,
you look good and you feel great.
You're kind of an arrogant ass.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
it's a cliche because it's true.
Everybody.
Mandy's understands this and that's why they've put it in their coffee and
they've also designed underwear that makes you look and feel fantastic.
You know,
you don't even need wear pants anymore.
Mian is made from Mo Dal.
Okay.
Model.
I Dunno.
A fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
Uh,
that's twice as soft as whatever underwear you're wearing right now.
Me undies has tons of colors and styles and the only place to get matching pairs
from men and women.
They even release a new design every month.
All those poor sweatshop kids.
Once they think that they've used all the material,
they got to go back it back out in the fucking woods,
you know,
go find another cotton tree,
right
diet with their own tears.
Plus,
we all know paying for shipping sucks.
So me undies has removed from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada shipped for free undies has even more money,
uh,
even as a money back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair of underwears,
if you fucking balls don't feel fucking great,
there's get the,
you get another pair for free.
Well,
why the fuck would you want another one if you didn't like the first one,
you literally have nothing to lose.
To sweeten the deal me undies is offering you 20% off your first order at
[inaudible] dot com slash burr that's a special offer for just my listeners in
every other podcast that these people advertise on.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] Dot Com to get 20% off your first order and so
that they know that we sent you [inaudible] dot com slash burr [inaudible] dot
com slash burr
hi
[inaudible] dot com slash birth all right.
Okay.
Dollar Shave Club.
Okay,
I've got to tell you guys something.
Shave and the old ways sucks.
A big bag of elk dick.
All right,
it hearts you lather up with cheap foam.
Wincing is the hair is scraped from your face with those old worn out God damn
razors that your grandfather used to use back in the war,
right,
but you won't draw them away because the new one's costs of God damn much.
Not Any
why?
Because it dollar shave club over there.
Dollar Shave Club sends amazing razors for a few bucks.
Where do they send them?
Wherever you live,
if you sign up with them and when you use them with their
members,
only Dr Covey,
bye.
It's completely changes the game.
My neighbor bed in a bitch,
I hit him,
her fucking kids screaming in the pool everyday.
Forget foam.
This stuff is the real deal.
It's magic.
Something happens when you put it on.
It's hard to describe,
but it feels amazing.
Jesus,
can you cop out anymore?
Why don't you describe it?
It's hard to describe,
but it's amazing.
Um,
it's most gentle.
Peaceful is the most gentle,
peaceful shave imaginable.
You barely know you're shaving and shaving products can leave your face feeling
dry and tight.
Awful.
Dr Carver's,
easy shave butter is high quality stuff.
Just like their razors.
It's got organic.
All natural ingredients like pear cactus and black willow bark.
God,
I can't wait to get that up against my face.
Just throw some fucking sandpaper juice in there while you're at it.
They're carby.
Uh,
so your skin feels fresh,
smooth and moisturized after every shave.
It's good.
It's great if you have sensitive skin.
Doctor cabbies,
easy shave bottom from dollar shave club is like nothing you've ever tried.
Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter.
Just one more reason to try dollar shave club.
Do it today.
Dollar Shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar high dollar shave club.com/bar last one.
Legal Zoom.
Everybody.
Do you want to the gut?
Do you want to,
the government became a Italian there right off the boat.
Do you want the government to decide what happens to your property and minor
children?
What,
when,
when I'm alive,
now what?
I'm dead.
I mean,
I'm in the ground.
I don't think I have an opinion.
Um,
it's not make the commitment to protect your family with the last will or living
trust today.
It's national.
Make a will month again this month@legalzoom.com.
That's 20 months in a row that has been national.
Make a will month and doing the right thing has never been easier.
They've created a better,
I can't believe that somebody had been walking around this country with a
sandwich board for the last fucking 20 months.
National.
Make a will month ringing that fucking cow bell.
Poor bastard Betty skinny though.
Huh?
Why can't it be a woman?
Well,
I dunno.
Good.
I don't give a fuck.
You want the job?
Take it.
Ah.
They've created a better way for you and your spouse to take control of your
family's future.
Checkout.
Legal Zoom is new.
Last will and living trust bundles.
Aw,
that's adorable.
The more you plan ahead with wills,
trusts,
and powers of attorneys,
the more you save and the more you can piss off people that are still alive
because you can say without a doubt in sound mind,
you are not getting that beautiful fucking leather chair that you always went
and sat down and every time you walked through the house like you fucking live
there.
It's not yours.
I'm giving it to Ethel.
Um,
even if you're confused about all the options,
don't that hold you back.
You can use their own online resources and estate planning tool to help you
figure out what you need or get more specific guidance from legalzoom's network
of independent attorneys in most states since they're not a law firm,
don't procrastinate when it comes to protecting your family.
Get legal help.
You can count on@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter bur bur are in the referral box at checkout to save even
more.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code burpee.
You are our legal zoom.com.
Um.
All right,
well I hope that was a little pain though.
Little less painful this week.
We've got great emails this week and everybody,
if you would like
to send a question to me,
uh,
you can email me at bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
That's the email bill@thempodcast.com.
Um,
all right,
let's talk about the local news,
shall we?
Uh,
yeah,
we got check in and our own,
our old friend now you remember,
you remember what's his face?
What's his face?
Rodney Dangerfield members.
Dr Vinnie [inaudible] bots.
He'd always be talking about him.
Well,
we hear on the podcast like to talk about our old friend,
only Anthony Anthony,
Monsanto.
See what that Goombas up to this fucking this month.
Do you know that those guys are over in India right now?
Monsanto and they have like a sister company right now and they're getting,
they're getting sued,
I believe.
Are they getting taken to court because India said,
we don't want genetically modified food.
Can you believe that?
They didn't want their food altered.
They probably looked at all the fucking poison people in this country.
And they're like,
well,
we don't want to be like that.
We already have a population problem.
Last thing we need is these fucking assholes fucking with that curry,
right?
That chicken or rice,
a fucking egg playing all that bullshit.
Right.
So what,
what does,
what does Anthony Dewey's a car?
He doesn't give a fuck.
He goes in there anyways and without permission allegedly takes a strain of
their own egg plant and genetically fucking modifies the thing.
And guess what?
They got fucking busted.
So now it's a big thing whether they're going to go to trial,
if people are going to go to jail and all that.
And you know what Anthony's doing?
He's just throwing money around over there cause he's going to find some corrupt
fucking politician who's going to say fuck this.
I'd rather have a big house
and fuck over a billion of my own countrymen.
Yeah.
Just so I can have a fucking Jacuzzi and a couple of God damn horse come over
there.
Can you believe that?
Um,
yeah.
Scotland actually outlawed genetically altered food.
Ah,
I wish this country
okay.
It's fucking unbelievable.
I'll tell you one thing right now because I'm not a well read guy,
but I can,
I can,
I can predict shit.
I can guarantee you that nobody who has any fucking remote shot of becoming
president basically,
I mean a candidate in the Democratic or Republican party,
nobody is going to bring up all Anthony.
They're not going to fucking do it.
They're not going to bring up how all these costs.
Okay.
Straw,
all these mines,
all this money at all these fucking politicians so that they can use words like
organic,
homegrown,
and all of that shit illegally when it isn't and it's just a bunch of fucking
poison.
You know what I mean?
I think it's fucked up,
dude.
I'm going to go on a limb and just say that's really fucked up.
So I want to keep an eye on that man.
Cause I went over there to India obviously,
and as I talked about before,
I did a Gig in the fucking people
coolest shit that funny as hell.
And I'm,
I don't,
I can't explain it.
I went over there and it just,
I can't explain it the way the fucking people couldn't explain how great the
underwear was or the shaving cream.
What are the fuck it was,
I know,
I just felt,
uh,
I just liked it over there.
Um,
so I liked the people and I hope that their food doesn't become fucked up.
Like the food is over here.
And as dumb as I am,
I am speaking from experience because as I told you guys,
I ate and drank like fucking Ernest Hemingway when I was over in France earlier
this year for 10 days.
And I put on only four fucking pounds.
I was crushing beers,
rich fucking meals.
I was eating fucking call made cream puffs every day and I came home and all
that gang was four pounds.
If I did that shit in this country,
I would have fucking game 15,
17 fucking pounds.
Um,
okay.
Telling you,
man,
this,
I don't know if there's something going on.
Believe me.
Don't believe me.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just throwing it out there.
And,
uh,
so I know you guys have any good stories about all our good friend there,
Anthony.
We'll see an Anthony Monsanto.
See,
uh,
you know,
we'll try to just keep an eye on them.
See what,
see what the fuck he's been up to.
Um,
all right,
so as I mentioned this time of year,
I actually start to pay attention to baseball because I fucking love October
baseball.
You know,
they fucking uh,
put all the extra Mike's in there and the crowd sound amazing.
It's cold.
You know the trophies on the line,
fucking legendary shit happens.
I can't wait,
you know,
so coming out of the dog days of summer here,
so I'm starting to pay attention.
So for those of you not paying attention,
my fucking red socks,
I have not.
I've watched one game this year.
There are 52 and 65,
a 0.44 winning percentage.
They are 12 and a half games out and they've played 117 games.
What are they pay one 62.
So they got about 40 fucking five games left.
Oh,
geesh.
Okay.
Oh my God.
If we want all 45 we could only win.
There's no way we can win a hundred games this year.
We need to go about 40 and five.
I think we got a shot at winning the division.
I actually know the fucking Yankees.
There's 64 and 52 we're not going to catch him,
but
12 and a half games out.
Yeah,
I'd say this is a rap.
Toronto's a half game out.
Loving that hope they keep plummeting.
I Love Baltimore and I love fucking Tampa Bay.
I like don't see,
I don't like,
I don't like Toronto.
He,
they,
they really belong in the fucking leave.
What are you doing here?
You know,
get your own sport.
You don't see us playing your sport.
Do you?
Fucking red sox lost again today.
Lost again today.
10 to eight put up eight runs and still couldn't fucking hold him off.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the standings here.
How's Kansas City doing?
Kansas City first fucking place.
Best record in the fucking American league.
I love it.
We went five and five.
Our last 10 Yankees went four and six.
Toronto and eight and two.
This surgeon,
Kansas City,
seven and three.
That's fucking tremendous.
Detroit's four and a half back.
Minnesota is one and a half back.
I,
you got yourself a race day and when the fuck did the Astros go to the American
league?
What the fuck happened there?
Who switched?
Milwaukee did a long time ago.
All right.
That's fucking weird.
Washington and Atlanta.
Miami,
Philly,
Saint Louis.
I don't get time to figure this fucking shit out.
All right,
so Kansas City's my team loved to see Kansas City.
I'm liking the match day long tortured fucking fans.
Even though they're new Yorkers.
I don't give a fuck.
Philadelphia.
Jesus Christ.
What happened in Philly?
Saint Louis has always fucking there.
Oh God.
They're gonna make a run again.
Jesus Christ.
St Louis.
Is there that fire?
What of what?
Of what a fucking whatever organization.
I'm sorry.
This is boring as shit.
He just listened to me looking at the God damn stats here.
Um,
all right,
here's something fucked up.
You guys see that story on Patrick Kane?
I shouldn't even set his fucking name,
that Patrick Kane story where he's getting,
he's charged with allegedly a,
what the hell is it here?
Let's make sure I get this right.
Um,
oh,
for God's sakes with the fuck is it basically he's charged with allegedly raping
somebody.
So some Douche bag is that is saying that the NHL needs to suspend them.
It's like did that right there is the reason why not only should the victim be
protected,
that the person being accused should be protected.
He shouldn't put the guy's name and face and drag them to the fucking mud.
You know,
am I the only guy who remembers that rolling stone story?
And that's not the only time that that has happened.
All right?
So in fairness,
considering what this guy has to lose,
he should be treated with the same respect as the alleged victim because it's
all a legend.
You shouldn't be fucking,
this isn't,
it's none of my fucking business right now.
You know what I mean?
Let it go to trial,
have the whole thing come out in the fucking wash.
And in the end,
if he's found guilty,
then not only suspend them,
you got to,
you can't have a fucking convicted rapist and yell,
let's the end of his career.
That's the point.
My voice just cracked it.
That's the end of his fucking career.
I'm not trying to uh,
attack either person here.
I'm just saying in the future they really need to start fucking doing this
because let's just play devil's advocate the way this blogger is.
His fucking talking about Patrick Kane.
Like he's already been convicted and just sit in there.
How are we holding our athletes and fucking blah,
blah,
and we just can't wrap our heads around that condescending
link fucking speak.
You know,
like I'm sitting there with a poster of him on my fucking wall in a racing car
bed.
Um,
Jay to people in power take advantage of it.
Wow.
What else do you know?
They are fucking no named blogger.
Um,
anyways,
I think that,
you know,
that they shouldn't put the,
they also should protect the accused and two,
because this guy has so much to fucking lose in the bottom line is once you get
accused of that shit,
it's fucking over.
Even if they find out,
even if the victim were to come out and just say,
Hey,
I made the whole thing up.
I don't know what I was thinking.
Sorry about that.
Fucking see you.
Right.
And of course you can say that as a woman and not go to fucking jail after you
just ruined the guys life.
I'm sorry,
I was just in a mood,
you know,
then I went out and I got some breakfast and I felt better and I realized,
you know what,
he didn't write may actually,
I kind of enjoy it.
So anyways,
that's what I'm saying.
You shouldn't say either person's name and then you know when it goes to trial,
if the person's convicted,
then tar and feather them.
I think that's more than fair,
don't you?
I Dunno.
So anyways,
so let me,
so here's the thing,
if Patrick Kane is acquitted of this,
if it doesn't go to trial,
don't be a fucking cunt and yell some Shit,
Adam at games when you know when your team's playing them,
cause you're mad,
you can't beat the fucking Blackhawks.
Don't be at dose.
All right?
But like I said,
if he fucking did it,
you know he should go to jail and uh,
right there.
Right.
Um,
I dunno.
Most fucking move on here.
Uh,
what w what else do I got?
How much fucking thought?
35 minutes.
Okay.
Um,
what else did I want to talk about?
I think that was basically it.
Yeah.
MMM.
I got anything else that got anything coming up?
I don't,
I'm just still fucking editing.
I'm
editing.
This F is for family.
Uh,
I gotta go back in tomorrow and all that type of shit.
I can't wait for you guys to see this shit.
I can't wait.
I believe I've got to wait until December to find
out if you guys think it's good or it's sucks.
But,
uh,
anyways.
Oh,
you know what I should do you guys mind if I read you some of them like fucking
dates here.
I got coming up.
I got to hate these fucking things.
I just added a whole run through Texas.
Um,
where the hell is it?
Oh,
here we go.
Okay,
Here we go.
Bill bird.com everybody.
Oh,
Bill bird.com.
Um,
all right.
September 11th in Los Angeles.
I'm doing the Jack Radio comedy show.
September 21st I'm an Austin,
Texas.
September 23rd I'm in Houston,
September 25th I'm in San Antonio,
Texas.
And on the 24th,
I believe that's a Saturday.
I'm going to the a Texas Longhorn Osu Games.
So I'll see you out in the parking lot.
Hit me up man.
If you fucking smoking some meat or whatever,
let me know.
Let me stand by his smoker like some stray cat.
You know,
I'll throw 20 bucks towards your tailgate or 40 bucks,
whatever you need.
Let us buy in.
Me and Virginia coming through town.
All right,
but all co I'll fucking reach out to me if you got some bullshit here.
This is Texas.
I would except bullshit and some other fucking state.
But this is Texas.
You guys are known for this shit.
Um,
we'd love to come by.
We'll bring some fucking top shelf booze.
We're going to be rooting for the longhorns.
Will have a good fucking time.
All right.
And then at the end of October,
October 22nd,
I'm going to be in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania,
uh,
the Hines hall for the Performing Arts.
October 23rd and we it play,
play House squares,
state theater and Cleveland,
Ohio.
October 24th,
I'm going to Indianapolis,
Indiana.
Gmr say country.
Uh,
I'll make sure I have enough air in the fucking microphone.
playing the murse theater.
October 25th,
I'm in Detroit at the Fox theater.
Uh,
the 26th,
I'm going to be in grand rapids,
Michigan.
28th,
Minneapolis,
Minnesota,
29th,
the Chicago Theater.
Um,
and then if in a November six and we'll be in Philly,
haven't been there in a long fucking time.
Usually play the tower theater.
I'm going to be playing another wells Fargo Center this time.
So,
uh,
I got a brand new our shit.
I'm going to be fucking doing a bunch of up between now and then.
So I give you guys your money's worth.
So,
uh,
please by all means come on out to the shows.
I would appreciate it.
All right,
and with that,
let's get back to the,
let's get to your questions this week.
I think of running my mouth enough about myself and what I've been up to and the
things that I find important.
Um,
all right.
Fat Shaming,
success story.
All right,
cool.
It was a rough one,
you know.
All right.
Hey Bill,
I'm six feet tall and five months ago I weighed 320 pounds.
Big Boy.
Jesus Buddy.
All right,
I'm now down to two 43 and trying to get around,
trying to get down to around 200.
I've been using your self shaming method and it's,
and it's obvious that it works.
I fucking love
that self shaming wins you getting in there,
how you're taking your shirt off,
standing in the mirror,
jumping up and down.
Look what your dad
and you and you fucking build yourself up turning around.
He said,
even though my people tell me I look good,
I don't let up on myself.
Thanks for the motivation to go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
man.
You got to do it.
You got to stay on yourself.
And this is the thing too.
I look,
this is a psychologically how I look at it.
I look at it like,
uh,
each,
each week is a game like in the NFL season.
All right?
I get on the scale.
I figured out how much fucking weight I need to lose.
All right?
I needed to lose like a good fucking,
you know,
I was a good,
Ooh,
oh Jesus.
You know my fighting weight,
you know,
when I had a blast,
I had a flat stomach goes between like one 62,
one 65.
So I was up to one 87.
So I needed to lose a good 2025 pounds.
All right?
So I figured,
you know,
I lose two to three a fucking week.
I'm looking at a good 10 weeks,
10 10 week season here.
So what I do is if I lose,
I have it on the,
on the calendar,
I write the weight that I'm at and every Sunday I just write down the weight
that I want to be the next Sunday.
And,
uh,
I weigh myself every day,
sometimes a couple of times a day I get fucking psychotic with it.
And,
um,
I try to make weight every Sunday and I tried and I tried to do it without
starving myself because then you just kind of eat away at muscle and you become
very fleshy,
very fleshy.
Um,
which is you just all gelatinous and shit.
You want the muscle cars.
I guess it eats the fat because that's what somebody in a bar who wasn't a
fucking nutritionist told me.
All right,
so,
and then how I,
how I do it.
So I don't fuck up is cause I know that there's no way I'm going to go 10
fucking straight weeks in,
eat absolutely perfectly.
I know at some point I'm going to fuck up and have a burrito and a Taco and a
fucking brought or whatever the fuck I did.
Um,
and I just tried to immediately get back on the stick.
And then that week,
if I don't make weight,
I just,
I call that week a loss.
And then I just look at my record.
I just pretend I'm a coach.
All right.
I was too.
And Oh,
now I'm two and one I can't go to and toe can't go two and two,
then the local fucking sport writers are going to give.
Those are trying to make a change,
you know?
So,
uh,
I won the first two weeks with this diet.
I lost the next one.
I tried to call it a bye week,
but I'll say that's a loss.
I was two and one,
then I won the next two weeks in a row on this week I was looking at a loss.
So instead of being five and one,
I was looking at foreign too.
And I didn't like that number and I just went really hardcore with the working
out and trying to eat as perfect as I could.
So I,
I just just look at it that way.
And if you,
uh,
you know,
if you fuck up or whatever,
it's not the end of the world unless you allow it to be.
And I think a lot of people,
myself included,
is when you,
when you fuck up on your diet
the next day,
what you have to watch out is when you eat a bunch of grease or sugar or salt,
you're going to wake up the next day and you're going to crave that shit.
Um,
so what,
you've basically started as a little fire that you can easily stomp out with
your fucking slippers while you're still in your bathrobe by just making
yourself a bowl of oatmeal or something healthy for breakfast and then you eat
that you're,
because you've been eating so well,
you're going to want to,
you're going to still be on that craven,
uh,
healthy stuff.
This is how it works for me.
Okay.
Obviously I'm not a nutritionist.
I'm not,
none of us know sports medicine,
nothing.
This is just what's working for me.
I've,
I've realized after years,
I think it was stupid when people said food is a drug.
I realized finally now that it is,
so when I fuck up,
you know,
and I basically,
in a food version,
you hit the crack pipe.
I just make sure the next day that when I get up like
okay,
before I even had like I,
you know,
I go for a walk,
I drink some water with some lemon and that will really calm you down,
you know,
so you don't get a fucking Danish or go out and get some waffles or some salty
fucking eggs and cheese and bacon and all that shit.
Um,
yeah,
that's what's been working for me.
So if you want to go from two 34 to 43 to 200,
uh,
just maybe,
you know,
try that.
If it works for you,
works for,
if it doesn't,
then I'm sure there's a zillion other things on the Internet by,
you know,
professionals,
but a,
I'm happy for you,
man.
That's fucking insane,
dude.
That's what,
three 20 to,
okay.
That's almost 80 fucking pounds.
77 pounds.
Dude,
that's unbelievable.
Good for you,
man.
Keep going.
All right.
Drought Shaming.
Oh God.
Hey Bill.
Up here in northern California.
We are on tight water restriction.
Pretty much everyone's lawns are dead or mostly Brown.
Personally,
it's driving me up the wall.
They have a dead ass yard.
But you know,
I'm going to do my part.
My issue is the selfish cons,
who have the fucking nerve to just flood that God damn lawns like their
specialists.
Something I want to drought shame,
uh,
the blatant water users in my neighborhood,
but I don't want to shit where I eat.
Do you have any thoughts or advice,
by the way?
We saw your show,
uh,
when you came to Sacramento and you killed now.
We hope you come back soon.
I'll thank you.
Um,
well look,
I never advocate Rad not ratting somebody out.
Um,
but it's a weird thing when,
when somebody is doing something that affects the whole tribe,
you know what I mean?
This isn't like a,
you know,
yeah.
The guy drove home.
I Dunno.
I whatever,
I'm trying,
I can't think of a fucking example.
This is something that really is affecting the entire state.
Um,
I,
I don't know what I would do.
Yeah.
Why don't we leave him an anonymous note and just say,
listen,
I'm not trying to be a jerk,
but we are in a drought.
Um,
you're not supposed to be watering your lawn and I'm not the kind of person to
rat somebody out.
That's what you do.
And I would really hope that you don't put me in a position to have to call the
local authorities about you watering the shit out of your fucking lawn.
So then basically what you did is you went passive aggressive.
You didn't rat him out.
You basically listen,
dude,
though we adopt,
but don't make me fucking do this.
But at the end of the day,
man,
I mean we're,
we're in serious fucking trouble here.
So,
okay,
that whole no snitching thing.
It's,
it's becomes a little bit of a gray area.
So why don't you give the guy a fucking chance,
you know,
don't be a cunt in the letter.
Just say,
please,
I don't rat people out.
But you know,
this is the needs of the state and the people in the state are way bigger than
you and your yard.
Please don't put me in a position.
You got to go walking.
I can.
True Romance.
When he fucking clasped his hands together,
like whatever.
He said,
I beg you,
don't put me in this position or something.
Whatever the fuck he said that that's what I would do.
So then you don't have to fucking rat them out then if you know he keeps water
in his yard lawn,
I don't know.
What do you do?
You know what?
You do your pussy out and you have your wife make the coffee.
I Dunno man.
I,
I really have zero tolerance when it comes to people.
Uh,
I don't know.
I bet.
But look at me.
I flew a fucking helicopter down to my fucking Gig and I'm not using bottled
water,
but this is,
my instructor was saying like,
Dude,
we just fucking sent leaded gas through the atmosphere.
So I mean,
I'm a fucking hypocrite too.
I don't know what to tell you,
but it does bug me when everybody else is trying to tighten the fucking belt and
there was that person just fucking water in the shower.
I'll tell you that
my neighborhood man,
they fucking water and the shit out of it.
I don't think,
I don't even have any grass and my fucking yard.
You know what I mean?
I've got a couple of I water the uh,
yeah,
I water the plants that are actually producing food.
My wife likes all these other fucking plants.
I was like,
well,
who gives a fuck about a plan if it's not,
feed me.
What the fuck do I care about it?
Let's get them Outta here.
Right.
So that's a bit of a fight.
But like some of my neighbors met,
it's like they wanted their shit and uh,
what kills me is not that they're necessarily watering it.
It's this sprinklers is so fucked up.
It's just shooting out into the street.
Okay.
Landing on the,
the hot tar and then just evaporating.
Um,
what they're really doing is spraying people's cars that probably just got 'em
washed,
which you're not supposed to.
I haven't washed my car and fucking months look too,
we're all fucking try.
And maybe that guy with the green lawn,
maybe he's doing something else.
I have no idea.
But,
uh,
you know,
look at me.
I mean,
I fucking,
I fly around in helicopters.
Who the fuck am I to say that?
I'm all right.
Here we go.
It's Phil Collins,
a good drummer.
Bill.
Bill,
insert generic redhead insult here.
Oh,
okay.
Thank you.
Uh,
what do you think about Phil Collins is a drummer.
His drummer was,
his drumming was a staple of the 80s,
but he never shows up on any greatest drummers list.
Uh,
as a drum enthusiast
yourself,
can you explain why is he not a great drummer as an average music listener,
but not a drum expert?
I think he's,
he drums like an awesome mother fucker,
but I know fuck all about the technicalities of drumming except,
uh,
what you shared is Phil Collins great or even good.
Please help.
Phil Collins is a fucking monster.
He's an unbelievable fucking drummer and he has his own sound.
And what I love is the time when he came up,
there was this fad of having no bottom head on your toms,
which are basically the,
the,
you know,
you have your bass drum or snare drums and then like,
basically,
you know,
someone doesn't feel Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
The plan,
those fucking things.
Those are your Tom Tom's,
right.
So there was a time where having no bottom head for whatever fucking reason,
and they were called concert Tom's,
there was people that just like that sound like they went through this whole
studio time in the studio I think where they were really deadening the sound
like drums or really had a dead sound.
And maybe that's why they did it.
I don't know,
I'm getting in over my head very quickly here.
But um,
he came up,
you know,
when I go all the way back to the,
the,
when he was just playing drums in genesis and Peter Gabriel was still in it and
they will,
that whole prog rock band.
Um,
I think even back then he didn't have any bottom heads and he has his own sound
and he's fucking lefthanded and he's an absolute fucking monster and I'm in the
air tonight.
That fucking drum fill.
That's one of those things that,
you know,
I guess if you played drums for three months,
you could mimic it,
but could you come up with it?
Um,
so why doesn't he get credit?
Well,
I would say because he played,
when he played drums in Genesis,
they were progressive rock band and I think it was,
I dunno,
it was just too fucking avant garde.
It wasn't pop.
So,
um,
he didn't quite get the credit.
And then when the 80s came around,
he kind of became the,
became the front man.
He became the singer and he'd go back,
there was a chest,
a Thompson and they'd have like a,
they play drums together,
maybe do a little drum battle or something like that.
But then it was considered,
oh wow,
look,
he can lose.
A lot of people even by the 80s were like,
oh,
he can play drums too.
They didn't know that.
He likes started off as a drummer.
He's one of those amazing guys that like,
you know,
is it like Dave Grohl where he's in fucking nirvana and your lead singer dies?
I mean,
you're usually fucked as a drummer.
That guy stepped out to the forefront and started his own band is become a front
man in his own right.
And I always talk about that and I never thought to think that Phil Collins did
the same thing on Peter Gabriel left and he just went out to right to the front.
Um,
Don Henley Henley's another guy,
but he always sang when he was with the eagles,
but end he was,
why does he get the credit?
I think because of songs like studio.
And he was completely overexposed in the 80s and he made really schlocky pop
music.
He went from being this underground outsider guy to just right in the cross
hairs and being the most successful guy of an age.
And then you,
you just get branded like you're an eighties guy and then the next decade comes
and everybody did the youth from that immediately revolts against whatever
happened the previous fucking decade.
And then the decade before is considered cool.
Like in the 80s,
everybody was about 60,
the 60s and the woods.
Woodstock was great.
Everybody hated fucking disco.
the 90s came around,
they were like,
fuck hair metal and all that stupid ass fucking shit.
And then all of a sudden the 70s became cool and the bgs were somehow being
played again and fucking,
uh,
dirt teglar Boogie Nights,
all of that shit,
dazed and confused.
All those fucking movies came out right in the 80s.
You had like fucking platoon and all that shit talking about the Vietnam War and
fucking Woodstock and hippies and all of that fucking crap.
Seventies.
What'd you have?
You had a happy days,
right bill?
We fucking get it.
All right.
So I think,
but when you're like,
uh,
the face of an era,
like people won't let you change and they,
they,
uh,
I don't think in the 70s when he was playing drums that they were popular,
popular enough that people understand how great a fucking drummer he is.
And,
um,
okay.
And then by the 80 [inaudible]
she's singing that cheesy shit that I absolutely fucking hate,
but derosa loves it and he's like 10 years younger than me,
so I don't know.
But I will say he played with the,
he so many fucking great tracks he played on.
He played on Robert Plant's,
uh,
I'm in the mood that that first solo album he did after Rod Zeplin had to break
up cause bottom died,
I believe it was his first solo album.
Just fucking amazing drums.
Okay.
For like a pop song.
And just as phrasing this,
the way he chooses,
I dunno just his,
the way he expresses himself.
I think he's a fucking monster and he gets extra cool credit notes because he's
a lefty.
Um,
I'd last I read about him.
He really fucked up his back as a lot of drummers did from his era because they
knew nothing about stretching and yoga and that type of shit.
And especially if you sang and you,
and they used to have like those Mikes,
so you'd be playing and you'd have,
you'd be turning your neck.
I know Don Henley fucked up his neck,
the one that,
um,
a lot of drummers that sang back then,
in fact,
if you look a lot of older drummers,
they go from having a drum throne to have and like that,
uh,
back,
like literally like a regular chair,
you know,
support that back.
And,
um,
but anyways,
I'm fucking rambling here.
He,
he,
he's a fucking monster.
Absolute fucking monster.
So,
uh,
but what I've heard recently,
he started playing again,
so maybe fixed his back,
but,
uh,
I read a real depressing article about a month,
a few years ago when rolling stone where he was like retired from drumming and
he was confused as to why he was called the antichrist,
you know,
because of his shit from the 80s.
And,
and uh,
I dunno,
I felt bad for the guy,
so I was psych one it heard he was drumming against.
So and if I get a chance,
I'm definitely going to go see him and I'll sit through all that studio
horseshit just to hear him play drums.
All right,
a fucked up cheating story needed.
Vice d uh,
dear bill.
Okay.
All right.
I could really use a advice on this.
I found out accidentally that my best friend since births girlfriend has been
fucking our other best friend behind his back for over a year.
Now wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Let me back up here.
I found out at that my best friends,
my best friend sends births,
girlfriend.
All right,
so your buddy,
since you were a toddler,
he has a girlfriend.
She's been fucking your other best friend behind his back for over a year now.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Okay.
Hey,
we go.
I was checking something on his phone and stumbled across naked pictures.
She had sent him shocked to see it.
I dug further.
Wait a fucking minute.
The fuck are you doing with this
phone?
What were you checking on his phone.
Okay,
wait a minute.
Okay.
What the fuck this,
this is?
This whole fucking thing is weird.
Are you the guy that's actually fucking your best friend's girlfriend and you're
speaking about yourself and the third person?
This whole thing is weird.
I was checking something on his phone.
I've never checked anything on any of my friends' phones ever.
Yeah.
You know,
if they handed to me,
I look at whatever picture is there.
I don't start swiping around and snooping.
You were snooping.
What kind of a fucking man?
Jesus Christ.
See a snooping on this guy's phone.
You stumbled across naked pictures whenever you stumbled across.
You kicked on that.
You clicked on the photo app and you scrolled through his photos
she had sent them and then what?
You send them to your phone and jerked off to it later.
I'm probably being too hard on you.
All right.
Shock to see it.
I dug further and read the texts between them.
Oh Jesus.
You would just failing yourself,
weren't ya?
Um,
I love what you just not fucking doing anything wrong either.
The next thing know I was,
I couldn't believe it.
So now I'm looking at his tax record and it's fucking social security number.
Uh,
anyways,
all right.
Shocked to see them.
I dug further and read the texts between them saying how much she loves him and
she wished they could fuck all day.
And it made me so sick to my stomach that I went into his tax records.
I'm sorry.
She's the nicest girl I ever met in my life.
And I look at her as a sister,
but now I see how bad she's been fucking a kid over.
That's like my brother with his best friend and I have no idea what to do.
He trusts them both so much that he had no problem with them going alone to
green bay for a football game.
Oh my God.
Ah,
Jesus.
And they probably fucked on one of the top of one of those cheese had thinks,
you know,
she'd been herself over it,
you know.
Goodness.
Uh,
now when I hang out with them from here on out,
how could I act normal when I know what's going on?
It would destroy my buddy if I told him.
If I tell them not only would I lose the friend I have
wait,
if I tell him not only what I lose,
the friends I have,
but this girl,
this is a girl he lives with would do anything we'll do anything for and it's
going to get engaged to her eventually.
The four of us are like family,
family,
some stucked in a fucked up position.
Could use your help here.
Should I tell him or let it play out?
No.
What kind of a fucking friend of you going to get married?
Man.
Jeez.
No,
you can't let that happen.
This is what you gotta do.
You gotta go out with the other two,
the the two dirty ones that are fucking around.
He got to sit down and just say,
listen,
I was snooping on your phone.
I shouldn't have fucking done it.
And I saw the pictures.
I know what's going on with the two of you.
All right.
Okay.
So can you guys please tell him before I have to,
and you have to tell them.
Yeah,
you can't just break it off.
You have to fucking tell him cause you're not going to break it out.
If you're going to break it off and you're going to start fucking again or you
lady are going to go fuck somebody else because you don't love this guy,
just go tell him and break up with them and get on with your life.
All right?
And just say,
I'm not judging either one of you,
but you know what the fuck do you want from me?
And you had to know that if you're going to do something like this,
eventually this was something like this was going to happen.
So there you go.
Good luck with that guys.
I'll be over here reading the cheeseburger.
He just fucking remove yourself from it.
All right.
And just to add,
I would say,
listen man,
you have,
you have until the end of the fucking weekend to tell him or I'm going to sit
him down and tell him,
all right,
that's it.
I didn't create this fucking situation.
Uh,
the situation is what the fuck it is because of your Dick and your pussy.
maybe not in that order.
Maybe in that aura,
what are you going to do?
And I would just fucking walk away.
And uh,
you know,
and I,
and I wouldn't judge,
he's the one of you guys sound like you're young.
I have no idea.
God knows I made plenty of fucking mistakes in my life in that area.
So I was like,
fuck you going to do okay?
They fucked up.
They fucked up and they just got to come clean and you let the shit fall where
it may,
I think what's his face,
Jim Croce.
He's got a bunch of songs that your buddy could listen to.
You know,
she's living in La with my best old best friend Ray,
a guy that she knew that she said she knew well and sometimes,
hey,
did he,
isn't that the way?
That's what you should do.
You should be singing that in the background when they confess and he isn't dead
the way they say it goes,
well let's forget all that and give me the number.
You can't find it.
So I can call just to tell him I'm fine to show,
uh,
overcome the blow.
I learned the ticket.
Well,
I only wished my words good.
Just convinced myself that it just wasn't we you,
but that's not the way it feels.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
you sick.
It all fucking saw.
Um,
that's Jim Croce operated by the way.
Another sad song.
Sad Song by Jim Croce.
Uh,
my walk is another one for you here.
My wife and I are two months away from the birth of our first child.
That's fucking awesome.
Congratulations.
I want to hear your opinion on one of the names we have been favoring.
First name Birdie.
Fuck you.
You're not naming a kid birdie.
You're full of shit.
I don't,
I don't buy this.
Okay.
I don't buy this at all.
First name Birdie,
middle name.
Oola U.
L.
L a short from my grandmother or Sula last name starts with a g.
Her initials would be B U G bug.
Is this too weird of a name?
Oh,
you fucking hipster.
Cont.
No,
it isn't.
Go ahead and name your fucking baby birdie.
You fucking dope.
I imagine the DMV calling her name or a teacher calling her name and roll call.
What do you think?
You know what I think you don't name a kid birdie.
Why would you do,
I don't understand.
People who got the,
did you ever get the shit kicked out of you for no fucking reason.
Okay.
When you were in school,
you are literally giving people a reason every fucking day to fuck with your
kid.
Why would you do that?
Okay.
Give her a pretty name Birdie,
you know,
uh,
you know why God gives someone like you sperm that works.
It's just,
it's just,
I don't understand it.
Okay.
I mean,
you know,
was I too harsh this week on people
is Birdie isn't like a,
you know,
want got to look that up right now.
I've got to look that fucking thing up right now.
You gotta be fucking shitting me.
There's no way.
Is that going to be like the new,
like Kathy birdies and they left sweeping the nation
Birdie.
That's a golfing term.
That's what you hit.
And badminton
birdie.
Yeah.
Girl.
Girl Name.
Okay.
Let's see the history of this birdie meaning of the name.
Well,
I remember there was lady bird Johnson.
Birdie was until recently,
a middle ladies
club,
what
Birdie was until recently,
a middle aged ladies club member wearing a bird decorated hat,
but now it's just kind of a vintage nickname.
Think Haiti
does that supposed to be Lucy Joe Josie eyes are going Mami.
Milly,
that's coming back into style in a big way.
Actress busy Phillips named her baby birdie inspired by First Lady Lady Bird
Johnson as did soap star Mora West in an earlier hey,
day of nicknames.
Uh,
the 1880s birdie was a top 200 name people who also like Birdie also like
Alabama,
Alfie,
Alfred,
Aspen,
blanche,
Cecily,
clover,
Dixie,
Franklin Hawk.
Who Fuck names their kid hawk.
Lynnora Oswald Os one.
First of all,
if,
if celebrities are naming their baby that it's a good fucking that that's a good
one to avoid.
Oh my God,
look at these fucking names.
Barrow,
remi ransom,
the fuck names that kid ransom vesper
when w I n
what?
Goddammit.
Zero
to Lucy,
t o u l o u s e to loose.
I looked at that and my fucking dyslexia.
I just saw a tool shed.
Okay.
Patients who named kit patients.
The fucking irony.
Then I just flipped out about that Dixie.
Wait,
why don't you just call her truck stop whore,
frank.
There's a normal one.
Franklin.
That's all right.
Gertrude.
Jesus Christ.
What's she banging someone in the fucking Gestapo.
Gretel.
Cosmo Guthrie.
Lottie maple.
Marilla dude,
these are fucking,
these are fucking white people.
Douche bag fucking names.
Oh my God.
These fleas.
Mortimer,
India.
Heron Heron.
That's like how black people say heroin.
Heroin.
He's on that.
Hell,
Ron.
You can name a fucking me kid.
A drug.
A slang for a drug.
Does these,
these fucking names are horrible.
Wait a minute.
Let me get to see popularity.
Okay.
These are the popular names I've got to keep
going with this podcast.
This is fuck Birdie as number four 69 on name.
Barry,
what the fuck is named Barry?
Yeah.
All right.
It reached its peak is like Casey Kasem.
The name Bernie reached its peak in 88 80 a two ranked at two 10
and then by the 40 wait a minute.
Did dropped all the way down to the fucking thousand where it belonged.
Okay.
Enter a different name.
All right,
let's enter it.
What's a worst fucking name I can think of?
What's a fucking Douchey name?
It hit hipster would know.
Would name their kid.
I'm going to go with Lampi.
Just looked over and saw lamp.
See if that's one.
No,
no.
Lampi is open if you want to be fucking original.
How about fridge?
Yeah,
for ID.
Gee,
it's something of fucking stupid white person when named their kid.
Uh,
we found 21 results.
There's no way anybody's name and their kid fridge.
I bet melty Hubbard,
Milt
melt popularity is 1000% this week.
And already CMC melt.
I was just taking some of the,
some of the fucking old singers back in the day.
It was angled.
Humperdinck.
How about a Ebeneezer?
I can't spell this.
Isn't there a Z in there?
Just for the record,
I'm spelling.
Okay.
EA.
Z.
E.
R.
No fucking results for that.
How go fuck yourself.
All right.
I gotta.
I gotta get one fucking name that comes out here.
Come on,
Ebeneezer.
Yeah,
Ebenezer.
Up as I,
you spell it.
And you guys still listening to this
boy named Ebeneezer boy name.
All right.
Meaning of Ebenezer Ebeneezer
is a name of a biblical place.
The stone set up by Samuel to mark his victory over the Philistines rather than
a person.
It was adopted by the British puritans as a first name and then exported to
America where it had some early popularity entering the top 1000 in the 1880s
cheese.
I'll tell you,
1880s was a rough time to be born.
Not only fucking the scurvy and all that fucking horseshit
had fucking names like Ebeneezer and Birdie.
Ah,
you can just feel they're itchy clothes with those fucking names.
Can you?
Um,
all right.
I can babble with this shift forever.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody has always,
if you would like to donate to the podcast but not spend any fucking money.
Next you go to Amazon,
just
swing by Bill bird.com first click on the march page and then click on the
Amazon link.
It'll take you over to Amazon,
won't cost you any extra money.
They'll kick me a little dough for sending traffic their way,
and then I kicked 10% of whatever they give me.
Two a,
the Saint Jude's Hospital Day,
you'd go,
that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
Uh,
have a great week and don't name your kid birdie.